yeah you know when welcome to the CEO
playing yeah good is LeBron so we got a
Spanish really does that that's it
epicduel here right I have 77 games
against him and scores minus 4 h 4
that's unusual hmm interesting so hmm if
I take it I just wonder if i take it i
mean the hey sorry for the moon I'm kind
of irritated by this may be still go
with this the move h4 shouldn't be that
helpful for him I think taking also was
interesting I think he will grab now
well let's think about something about
from I can also take with the night
don't think h4 is it helps on the move
okay keeps taking a while maybe he will
actually play Bishop f4 or yeah well
that's the only M alternative yeah so um
Knight takes Knight takes before I have
be five that's an interesting one try to
make a gambit out of it I don't worry I
won't take that that looks very passive
I take the pawn I rather want to play d5
getting my own development up to speed
if you play something like a leaf I've
then I can take but that seems unlikely
[Music]
it looks fine for black anyway which so
Queen cheeks now I think and why not
critics and now I came the episode g4
looks like a very normal move this is
one thing I thought about about all this
for a moment and it was about this
situation that I have the bishop here
check that is quite useful to have so
fatigued here it'll take with the Queen
oh I can also do this yeah that doesn't
look bad right just attack the pawn that
pawn looks vulnerable and he has given
up on castling that cannot be all that
grade let's it's now interesting i can
take with the night as well
I wonder about it looks like a very
logical and take with the night but
Queen takes is isn't bad either had it
looks at they have three night and I
cannot be bad I have night f5 on the way
get it sir it's also a good move now
that's good 95 I can just take you 1 yes
that will win me the default pawn I just
wonder if I have something better
probably not take I'm going to win the
porn unless he's got d5 ok I cannot
worry about this and night takes or
group shakes I don't know you probably
not I not shown it is a huge difference
so let's go let's do this preventing any
h5 business I'm essentially just a full
blown up this one that looks unluckier
what is he doing now I don't quite
understand going there King is seven
probably 95 comes I wonder ever should
go see 6cm night a form and 94 is a bit
annoying to keep his rook passive this
is intending whoopty form I think if he
liked and he can shake me then
[Music]
no but I can I came first here I'm
improve my position he cannot do much
anyway at least I don't see n so here
possibly intending movie seven and
rookie a droopy seven is a is a direct
trade which should be 9 cm so let's
activate the King p5 look check Oh
didn't see that okay it's not a big deal
I think at least maybe I'm wrong so
let's see here King might come to f4
that's a little bit no I have to have to
have to focus him I'm drifting a bit in
this ending and this is not not
necessary at all
time warning and I said I'm not playing
this particularly well I did not it was
absolutely not necessary to give him
this King King activity how am i doing
this he actually 95 would actually it
was a trade at least with check so he
can he cannot take actually that that's
good I didn't plan any of that but its
lucky actually now so let's see ya maybe
just do this it's a bit lame to go
around like that but he's just now he
has a passive Rukia it is the key thing
and then against no check what's
happening here that's it does not good
not good technical check before I've
screwed this up I really screwed it up
before I probably have to go b5 and not
that that probably does not win not good
I cannot move my king here it's funny
ready check check check check check
check white forfeits on time Oh tough
game that place is really badly from
here that was extremely badly technical
play extremely bad technical play okay
so let's have a look at the opening and
hy I don't really believe in that move
but yeah the engine wants to play Knight
to f6 just developing let that make
sense now I me now we get just a
position that I know it's okay but with
h4 h 6 inserted I don't really know who
benefits am-9 txt force and also after
which I would have played be five leads
to gather it's a complicated plane
yeah he went went with this and then I
don't know after the five I think I'm
fine ah the engine gives Queen takes
let's not a move that I thought about
[Music]
the castle yeah but i think the engine
is giving this here with compensation
let that's possible i am there should be
six queen a form like it's quite active
damn possible yeah this is probably not
great iam I mean this position is really
good for black check Quincy for then
knight c6 was also stronger this is not
bad I mean he went 95 which gives away
the pawn but other moves I even worse I
think so because the elected as i know
i'm just playing badly h5 is okay and
also up to here I'm fine but I'm really
giving him all this King activity which
was necessary at all I mean this this is
also ok starting with this I'm doing
doing strange things um computer wants
to go be five now that's a google not
abandoned but but I don't think this is
all this is what check was an oversight
I just didn't think about the check and
now somehow he's getting too active them
and Brooke t2 does this is a bad move
I'm not really in 98 oh that would swim
stuff check oops instead this and now
things are not clear right yeah I was
lucky to to get get to this position
Kings is six
more precise yeah that been thinking I
was just thinking that it should be
winning mr. they came with the route
behind the pawn that white is coming
around there I am check remarkable yeah
now I could have done that but but here
there is no there's a win check now here
at least I'm checking porn but he is
extremely active I thought you could
just go here after which would be five
is just a draw but ok when he is so
active he might he may be can do that
but this really didn't feel very nice a
check check and check I have this
counter checking ID on the g3 yeah no
black wins ok that was heavily
influenced by the lack of time on both
are both both ends ok guys thanks for
watching